翻訳: Saneyuki Nishigame
校正: Hiroko Kawano
こんにちは はじめまして
さて チャイルド・ライフ・スペシャリスト
この職業をご存知だった方
いらっしゃいますか？
いらっしゃらない...
もっと頑張って働きます
（笑）
この職業は 北米で生まれた専門職
私は毎日 病院で
子どもや家族と関わっています
今日は 私が
子ども達から教えてもらった
「受け入れる」ということについて
お話ししたいと思っています
「受け入れる」という姿勢でいると
少し楽になったり
違うものが見えたり
今を大切に生きられる
そんな気がしています
北米の資格なので
私もアメリカに留学して
この資格を取りました
これは 私が初めて
実習をした保育園の様子です
肌の色 かみの毛
文化的背景 家族背景も 様々
パパが２人 ママが２人
アジアやアフリカからの養子
という家族も
少なくありませんでした
「みんな違って みんないい」
ということ
そして本当にたくさんのことを
学んだ保育園です
でも 私は
英語が得意だった訳ではありません
大学入試 センター試験の
英語はさんざんでした
なので 保育園での実習は
わりと大変で
子どもが言っていることが分からない
伝えたいことが伝わらない
そんな毎日でした
私が特に 苦手だった言葉は
この動物 リスです
皆さん 英語で何というか
ご存知ですか？
今でも上手に言えませんが
「Squirrel」と言います
RとLがいっぱいなんです
5歳の子に 真剣な顔で
「Repeat after me.」
と練習させられました
（笑）
何度頑張っても
上手に発音できないので
「It’s not squirrel, SQUIRREL!」
と怒られました
何が違うのかも分からなかった...
そして 不幸なことに
この大学の構内
リスがいっぱいいたんです
（笑）
「あ リスがいるね」と言うたびに
へこみました
最初 私は
上手に英語を話そうと頑張りました
必死でした
でも そんな時
指導教官の先生が言ってくれました
「あなたは確かに英語は話せない
私達と同じように
子どもと関わることはできない
でも 言葉が不自由な分
私たちには見えてないものが
見えている
あなたにしかできない
関わりがある
だから そのままでいいのよ」
何だかとても楽になりました
できない英語を上達させようと
もがくのをやめて
できない自分を受け入れて
あきらめて
「私 英語できないの 教えて」と
ありのままの自分で 子どもと
向き合うようになりました
すると不思議なもので
子どもの方も私のことを
受け入れてくれて
どんどん楽しく深く
関われるようになりました
ありのままの自分を受け入れて
ありのままで相手と向き合うと
お互いに 少し心を開いて
良い関係が築けるのかな
そんな気がしています
仕事の一場面を紹介します
お医者さんごっこです
これは 子どもがいつも受けている医療—
検査や注射などを
子どもが先生や看護師さん役になって
人形にする という遊びです
この遊びの中で 子どもは
自分が受けている医療
自分の病気のこと[を]
理解したり振り返ったり
何かしら気持ちを昇華していく―
手助けになればいいなと
思っています
私はこの遊びの中で
子どもたちに「痛い時は泣いてもいいよ
嫌な時は泣いてもいいよ」
ということを伝えたいと思っています
印象的な女の子がいました
当時4歳
彼女は定期的に
注射が必要でした
彼女は 注射の前
「私 絶対 泣くから」と宣言して
この処置室に歩いて行きました
すごいことだと思います
泣くほど嫌なことがある場所に
自ら歩いて向かう
彼女なりに
どうして注射が必要なのか
何をするのか 分かって
受け入れていたんだと思います
この処置室に着いて
処置台に座った彼女は
宣言通りに泣きました
廊下中に響き渡る大きな声で
「ぎゃー」と
でも 腕は動かさなかった
じっとしていました
そして 注射が終わると
けろっとした笑顔で
こう言いました
「あー きょうも ないちゃった
でも わたし がんばったね」
子どもが こう思えたら
大丈夫です
でももし 例えば
「男の子は泣かない」とか
「泣かない子は 強い」
という言葉を重ねていたら
泣いた時「私は弱い子」
と思ってしまうかもしれない
同じように泣いて
嫌なことを乗り越えた時に
「泣いたけど 私ってすごい」
と思えるか
「泣いた私は ダメな子」
と思ってしまうか
この気持ちの差は
大きいと思います
楽しいとか嬉しいという
何だか一見
良さそうな気持ちだけでなく
悲しい、怒ってる、泣きたい
そんな気持ちも
「あり」だと思います
悲しい相手 悲しい自分
怒っている相手 怒っている自分も
許し 受け入れたいと思っています
ちなみにですが先ほどの
「泣く宣言」をしていた女の子は
いつの日か いつものように腕を出して
「ぎゃー」っと言いながら
「あれ 涙が出てない」
と自分で気がついて
泣かずに
注射を受けるようになりました
もう一つ
私が 仕事の中で
大切にしていることを紹介します
これは 私が
アメリカでボランティアをした
子どものためのホスピスです
とっても素敵な施設でした
ここでボランティアをするときの研修で
こんなことを言われました
『「サポーティブ・インパクト」
ではなく
「サポーティブ・エンバイロメント」
であってください』という言葉です
今の私が日本語を考えるなら
サポーティブ・インパクト というのは
何か与える してあげる
という一方通行の矢印
サポーティブ・エンバイロメント
というのは
何かするわけではなくて
ただその人のことを思って そこにいる
寄り添うという姿勢かなと思います
日本で働き始めたころ
印象的な男の子の言葉を聞きました
小学生の男の子
その日は 病棟で
お楽しみ会のイベントをしていました
彼の部屋に行って
「イベント行く？」と声をかけると
彼は 言いました
「今日はいい やめとく
だって気つかうじゃん
笑ってあげないといけないでしょう？」
私は はっとしました
子どもは 大人の
「楽しませたい」「笑ってほしい」
という気持ちを
空気を読んで 気を遣って笑ってくれることが
あるんだなと思いました
でも 私が目指すのは
気を遣って笑ってくれる関係じゃない
嫌な時は「嫌」と言える
「あっち行け」と言える
泣きたい時は 一緒に泣ける
そんな関係でいたいです
誰かの力になりたいと思う時
気をつけていないと
サボーティブ・インパクト ―
「してあげる」「楽しませる」「笑わせる」
「私が」 笑ってほしい
「私が」 役に立ちたいという
「私が」が主語になってしまう
ことがあります
そのときその人は
笑いたくないのかもしれない
泣きたいのかもしれない
ただのんびりお昼寝が
したいのかもしれない
「私が」という
自分の気持ちを少し引っ込めて
ありのままの相手を受け入れて
違いを受け入れて 寄り添う
という姿勢でいられたら
その時その人が本当にしたいこと
本当の気持ちが
見えるのかもしれない
そんな気がしています
さて プレゼンも後半です
ここで「命」について
考えてみたいと思います
「100％」
これは何の数字でしょうか？
私も含め 私たちが死ぬ確率です
当たり前のことですが
普段はあまり意識しないかもしれません
でも 私たち みんな死にます
私は この事実をどう受け止め
受け入れようか？ よく考えます
ここに 希望が見出せるのではないか
と思っています
ちなみにですが 子どもの病気は
とてもよく治るようになりました
例えば小児がん、白血病などは
8割を超える子どもが元気になって
大人になると言われています
ただ 病院で働いているので
時々は子どもが亡くなり 見送る
という経験もしてきました
２人の男の子を紹介します
右が たいじゅ君
左が よしき君といいます
この写真の時で
高校１年生と中学3年生
これは 中高生のみんなで集まって
たこ焼きパーティをした時の写真です
この素敵なサングラスは
彼のジョークです
「この写真使うのかよ？」って
怒られるかもしれませんが
２人はガンダムが好きで 仲が良くて
お互いに支え合っているような
関係だったと思います
まず たいじゅ君の話から
たいじゅ君は 中学生の時に
病気が発症し
一旦は元気に退院したのですが
高校になるころ 病気が再発し
もう治せないという状態になりました
16歳の時でしたが
彼は 医師から「もう治せない」
ということを聞きました
そして 抗がん剤の治療は
気持ち悪くて辛くて 大嫌いだったので
最後は 自分で
「もうこれ以上治療はしない」
と選び 決めて 亡くなりました
治療をやめて 亡くなるまでの間
彼がとても穏やかに
家族と思い出話をしたり
ガンダムのプラモデルを作ったり
会いたい人に会ったりして
過ごしていたのをよく覚えています
印象的なエピソードがありました
この写真のように
中高生が集まってたこ焼きを作れば
カラシ、ハチミツ、チョコレート
入ります
これはまさに チョコレートを持って
ニヤついている写真なんですけど
そんなたこ焼きをよく食べさせられていた
看護師さんがいました
リアクションが抜群で
みんなで楽しくおしゃべりをしていたとき
たいじゅ君が
その看護師さんに聞きました
「ねぇ たこ焼き 何が一番まずかった？」
その看護師さんは答えました
「グミだね ブドウのグミが最悪」と
すると たいじゅ君は私に言いました
「佐々木さん 分かった？グミだって
今度のたこ焼きの時
忘れずにグミ用意しなきゃダメだよ」と
「今度のたこ焼きの時」というのは
もう自分がいない時
自分は参加できないたこ焼きパーティです
彼は 自分がもうすぐ死ぬ
という事実を
もちろん色んな気持ちが
あったと思いますが
そんなユーモアをもって受け入れていた
そんなふうに感じています
そして
こんな手紙を残してくれました
「最後まで楽しく過ごすことができて
幸せだった
今までありがとう」
次に よしき君の話です
たいじゅ君ともお互いの夢の話を
していたそうですが
夢は漫画家
でも そんな彼も
たいじゅ君を見送ってから
病気の再発が見つかりました
そして彼もまた 医師から
「もう治せない」ということを聞きました
それでも彼は最初
「治すために治療を続ける」といって
病院で辛い抗がん剤治療を
続けていました
その頃 印象的な会話をしています
よしき君が
「たとえ機械につながれて動けなくなっても
治療を続けていれば
それは頑張って生きてると言えるのか？
諦めていいのか？」[と]
今まで 「病気に負けるな 頑張って闘え」
そう言われ
そう強いられてきた彼らです
そんな彼らは 医師に
「もう治せない」と聞いてもなお
治療をやめることは諦めること
そう感じるのかもしれない
と思いました
私は 彼に言いました
「治療をしても しなくても
どんな治療を選択しても
それはどう生きるか？
という生き方の選択
諦めではないよ
どんな選択をしてもいいんだよ」
そして彼は今
こんな風に言っています
「治すことは あきらめた
でも 生きることは あきらめない」
そして今は 治すためではなく
少しでも 家族といい時間を
過ごすということを目標に
副作用の少ない薬に変えたり
薬の量を減らしたり
という選択をしています
「生きることはあきらめない」
そう言うよしき君は
「時間を大切に生きたい
自分にできることをしたい」
と思っているそうです
そして例えば
愛知県知事に
「病院に院内高校を作ってください」
というお願いの手紙を出しました
みんなのためです
そして その手紙がきっかけで
今年の4月から正式に
高校の院内訪問教育が
制度化されスタートしました
自分の命の限りを受け入れて
今を大切に生きようとしているよしき君
本当に 大きなものを
残してくれたと思っています
命は 誰でも
必ず終わりがやってきます
大切なのは その時間の長さではない
と思っています
命の時間が長くても 短くても
自分に与えられた命の時間を受け入れて
その時間をどう生きるのか？
それが大切です
どんな選択 どんな生き方も
価値あるものです
生き方—
日常も たくさんの選択の繰り返しです
悩むのも当然 迷うのも当然ですが
どんな選択をしても
あとから振り返ったときに
「良かった」「幸せだった」と
自分で自分の選択 生き方をとらえ
受け入れられたらと思っています
それは 彼らが私に
教えてくれたことです
最近 よしき君は
「死ぬのは怖い」と言います
当然です
でも こうも言っています
「でも 楽しみもある
また たいじゅ君と遊べるじゃないですか」
最後に この言葉を紹介します
変えることができるものについては
それを変えるだけの勇気を
変えることができないものについては
それを受け入れるだけの心の平静を
そして変えることができるものと
変えることができないものを
見極めるための賢さを与えてください
私も
私に与えられた命の時間を受け入れて
不甲斐ない自分も受け入れて
今を大切に生きたいと思っています
ありがとうございました
（拍手）